[Music]
thank you
during the age of the dinosaurs
spectacular species like this
pachycephalus or attract the most
attention
but the prehistoric world was also home
to a wide variety of other quite
different species
so what were some of the animals living
alongside the dinosaurs
all right
one of the most surprising
was this
[Music]
the biggest frog to have ever lived
be Elizabeth was an especially large
wide-bodied frog with a proportionally
large head
it was the size of a small dog The
Fearsome Hunter
with an appearance to match
it had armored skull bones and armored
backbone heavily reinforced and big
strong Jaws
beelzebufo pad an especially powerful
bite
it would have been able to grab and
subdue and kill even relatively large
prey up to the size of baby dinosaurs
not by dinosaurs
but by marine reptiles
the largest were mosasaurs
these giant Marine lizards could reach
50 feet in length
wage 15 Tons
they had massively elongate powerful
jaws huge door muscles and enormous
conical teeth
they were the greatest Marine predators
of all time
but while giant lizards like this
Mosasaur ruled the oceans
a very different group of reptiles
filled the skies
in the air we've got this fantastic
diversity of flying reptiles that we
call pterosaurs
these things are often referred to as
flying dinosaurs but they're not
these were the very first animals with
backbones to fly
a wingspan rangs from 10 inches
to an enormous 33 feet
the largest posed a deadly threat for
even the most fearsome of dinosaurs
they were not just very big they also
had a skull that was about three meters
long and ended in giant stabby Jaws
you were Tyrannosaurus you would
probably think twice about approaching
an animal that dangerous
many of the impressive creatures on the
prehistoric Planet looked completely
different from anything alive today
[Music]
but there were also some animals that
might seem a little more familiar
mammals
despite people thinking that the
Cretaceous was all about dinosaurs there
were tons of mammals
we find things that lived in the water
like beavers today
we see things that were running around
in the trees and even gliding and things
that were living under the ground and
digging into the soil and you see
mammals evolved a lot of characteristics
related to being able to move around at
night
these Lifestyles may have been important
in helping mammals avoid the dinosaurs
living alongside them
they evolved a lot of different tools to
help them survive during that period
fur
being warm-blooded
even evolving big brains and sensory
structures that allow them to see at
night time
in fact we may have dinosaurs to think
for the way mammals look today
[Music]
after 150 million years the dinosaurs
were wiped out by a massive meteor
strike
in their place
mammals became the dominant life on
planet Earth
as they still are today
[Music]
thank you